hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem real live
video über einen tag von mir habt
richtig gehört ich bin für einen tag
morgens nach london geflogen um 5 uhr
und abends wieder zurück geflogen um 20
uhr mit einer freundin und ich habe da
ein paar sachen gefilmt ich habe
angefangen bei der zugfahrt auf dem
hinweg dann im flieger habe ich was
gefilmt in london habe ich richtig
richtig viel gefilmt und dann habe ich
auf dem rückweg im zug oder was wir
finden wir im flugzeug auch noch also
wirklich alles festgehalten das ist 60
minuten rohmaterial was ich euch jetzt
irgendwie auch zehn minuten
zusammenschneiden werde und auch ein
bisschen kürzer keine ahnung wie lange
es ganz wichtig dass er jetzt ich würde
auf jeden fall sagen viel spaß beim
video wenn es euch gefällt dass ich euch
mitnehmen wenn ich irgend welche
städtereisen ein bisschen was von den
falls nicht von der stadt allgemein
mitkriegt von dem leben in der stadt von
der umgebung dann gibt auf jeden fall
mal einen daumen hoch und scheine
kommentare und dann will ich sagen viel
spaß
wir sind gerade gelandet london gatwick
und ich laufe jetzt sogar flughafen her
unter seinen rund um computer sieht
sowas ja grad angeht
im zweiten fall jedenfalls war der flug
ein ich ganz schön ich also eine stunde
geflogen von düsseldorf kommen wir auf
jeden fall weitermachen so ein tagestrip
und jetzt vergleich mit dem gateway
carport travel express teil city will
dann ein bisschen frühstücken und dann
zeige ich euch wieder so ein paar
ausschnitte und da unten stehen läuft
die ganzen welt unterhalten
sicherheitspersonal hinter mir habe ich
gleich
sitzt im zug sondern nacheinander wohin
victoria station war schon dann kam
alles zu finden wir haben einmal 43
kommen uns alle dinge nicht richtig
weiter helfen sie mir einfach in wohin
gelaufen jetzt glaub ich im falschen zug
ich glaube wir sitzen wirklich im
expressen wir haben zig die den normalen
zug aber das soll uns das sagen wir sind
jetzt hier in der victoria station die
sehr
pompös eingriffs ist
der riesige ist also vielleicht waterloo
station ist natürlich ein experte jetzt
laufen wir zu helfen weg für mich
wahrscheinlich wieder so umwelt sachen
in der umgebung und dann laufen immer
noch durch den sohn james und gelangen
gleich zur westminster abbey fahren wir
dann so ein paar dinge machen die
branche seien das essen oder ins land
gehen und dass wir denken ganz cool und
das auch irgendwie krass ist so in
deutschland wenn du dich so films da
guckt nicht alle direkt an hier in
england akzeptieren dass einfach die
nicht die kupplung zu wahren aber egal
das ist
bei mir angekommen
helfen tun
der minister
wir laufen hat er und die sind mega mega
viele autos einfach wieder viele leute
hätte gar nicht gedacht
steigern
er muss dafür denken nur weil 4
am montag das heißt ja nicht dass sehr
viele leute nicht setzen
wird jetzt irgendwie daran bisher
ich wollte gerade ins mcdonald's gehen
aber haben sie das anders überlegt was
ist das ja auch in deutschland gibt
das heißt wir gehen jetzt irgendwo hin
sachen gibt die nicht so auch nicht so
dass kris humphries
und hier kommt doch mal mit
eine coole gasse
und wenn sich doch spaghetti wir stellen
dann aus der senke sagt margarita
irgendwie gesagt ohne alles das ist was
bekommen habe
wirklich rosig
das ist irgendwie das zweitgrößte 100
euro
immer noch in london
wer jetzt gedacht im auftrag von
fahrgast vor die fahrräder abstellen
können super plan das für uns fahrräder
ausleihen und dann vom leib ist hierhin
beim fahrradfahren ist perfekt geklappt
werden zehn unfälle geworden dass
bundeskasse auch hier wird alles gefilmt
worden
kaffee in mirow
das ganz cooler sich das ist
solche sachen wünschen deutschland wo
man quasi einfach wichtig so imhof
verlag bekommen
pellegrino verschiedenen richtungen das
sogar
diese aber irgendwie weiß ich nicht
super
wir sind jetzt am dickdarm gelangt man
merkt dass es jetzt so hinbekommen
trident sonnenblick hier
und da
die leinwand
ja nicht so riesig es eigentlich
da war
der durchbruch
und ein karamell
aber ich glaube nicht
jetzt bei starbucks
ich bin das habe ich gerade jetzt noch
mal so einen tick therapie sowohl was
sind dann einfach macht es total
richtig schön wir sind jetzt bei der
seinen vorzügen angekommen im taxi das
rad ein bisschen zeit um das alles raus
es ist nicht so groß wie der kölner dom
größer aber das ist schon passiert
vor allem überall wird es in ganz london
überall so richtig
leben aber richtig kleine leben war das
gut
wahrscheinlich hat in der stadt gesehen
gut gelaufen und die leute die polizei
interessiert einfach nicht die steht
daneben mit pferden nicht film die auch
noch die machen nichts sagen nicht nur
lassen
der verrat immer eingeschlafen so halten
doch mal was da am flughafen nicht weil
wir nichts anderes kind aus dass man so
einfach weil es aber zu klein ist und
weil sie das in deutschland nicht selten
nicht selten ich habe mir das anders und
ich habe mir ein rudel unter mehreren so
naturnah und zwei apple juice damit sie
nicht hartz iv bekommen wir halten kann
man deutsch nicht umtauschen
das wasser rauscht leise da sind wir vom
flughafen im auto wieder nach hause
gefahren
ich lag dann um 1 uhr im bett und war
total cup und habe jetzt erst mal elf
stunden geschlafen und bin immer noch
total ko weil wir wirklich ein ganz dumm
gelaufen sind haben alle möglichen
sachen erlebt und ausflüge neben einem
jahr einfach krassen mit das ist zwar
nichts das ist gar nicht da sitzt man
nur um
aber es ist trotzdem wie krass wenn man
jetzt viel fliegt und das ist einfach
total anstrengend auch wenn man einfach
auto fährt mal sitzen darum das ist
total anstrengend
jedenfalls war es auf jeden fall ein
richtig richtig richtig geiler tag ich
mache so etwas bestimmt auf jeden fall
noch mal einfach ein tag auch es muss ja
nicht wieder london sein sondern ist ja
schon relativ weit weg also wenn man
irgendwie nach münchen fliegt man dann
irgendwie auch eine stunde oder so aber
es ist halt noch in deutschland dann hab
ich da auch internet alles mögliche und
ich denke ich werde was auf jeden fall
noch mal machen also noch mal wenn ihr
das wollt dass ich mehr davon mache und
allgemein euch auf mehr so videos von
mir freuen wenn ich irgendwo an ständen
wenn dann zeigt man mit einer bewertung
oder schreibst und kommentare
und da würde ich sagen ist und euch noch
ein schönen tag